[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Волинь, Луцьк]
— Добрий день!
[Василь Рижук
скульптор]
Я — скульптор, архітектор.
Але в цей період життя я зрозумів,
що якщо ми самі в житті не почнемо змінювати ситуацію,
яка складається, яка є,
то за нас ніхто це не зробить.
Ми повинні весь час орієнтуватися по тій ситуації,
яка складається навколо.
Дороги в нас ви бачите в якому стані,
але добре, що вже почали будуватися,
тому що я коли починав цю справу робити,
то ще дороги були надзвичайно погані.
А узбіччя взагалі, ніхто не косив, навіть,
казали, що не вистачає коштів.
Бур'яни були такі високі-високі.
Борщівник був набагато вищий за соняшники мої декоративні.
От я і задумав змінити ту ситуацію.
У мене немає жодного метра землі.
Це прибудинкові території людей.
Але люди побачили, що я роблю гарну справу,
вони мені дали свої ділянки,
і ось тут я вирощую розсаду,
і роздаю по всій Україні всім, хто мене просить.
А у мене один раз виросло на дорозі, на 101 кілометрі, 128 квіток!
Так. З одного стебла.
Це був рекорд.
І так подумаєш:
25, 50, 60 [квіток], а 128 ще не виростало.
Але виросло!
Ось бачите. Це є узбіччя.
Воно заросте таким зіллям.
Отаке було велике зілля, надзвичайно велике.
А цілий рядок цих соняшників виросте,
і ось із такої висоти будуть дивитися квіти.
Розумієте?
Минулого року це було 67 кілометрів узбіч.
Коли цвіли декоративні соняшники і чорнобривці — люди всі дякували,
і передавали мені низький уклін.
Мені було приємно.
І люди дивувалися, у них поліпшувався настрій,
казали: «Ми не думали, що Україна починає змінюватися».
От бачите, вже де посаджено [рослинність],
то, як одна жінка казала: «Вже гарно зелене росте».
Бо це не тільки квітка радує,
а сама зелена маса, якщо вона ритмічно, композиційно розсаджена,
вона теж прикрашає.
От бачите, вже зупинки змінилися.
Вже воно по-іншому все.
Я виїжджаю о п'ятій годині, опів на п'яту, часом о четвертій.
Тільки починає світати — я зразу їду на роботу, на дорогу.
П'ятсот тридцять вісім з половиною кілометрів узбіч за 20 років [посадив].
Але інтенсивно — це за останні роки.
Торік було по цій дорозі — 67 кілометрів.
От ми вже скільки проїхали, оці всі узбіччя були в квітах.
Так Україну побудуємо [сміється].
Це так сказати легко, а спочатку мені 25 метрів уквітчати було дуже важко,
бо я не знав яким методом це зробити.
Коли навкруги — така трава, бур'яни,
і там щоб росли квіти.
Але з часом, як кажуть, людина практикується,
і ти щораз долаєш кілометри.
Чорнобривці і ці декоративні соняшники цвітуть найдовше —
це три-чотири місяці, а можуть і пів року.
Два місяці проходить поки вони не квітнуть, а просто — зелена маса.
Це символ України.
Тільки оце доведеться так до кінця посадити.
Може, я для когось і дивним здаюсь зі сторони,
але диваки якраз і є рушійною силою держави.
Аби диваки були направлені в кращу сторону, а не в гіршу.
О! Які вони красиві!
Різні: там — такі, там — такі.
Так вони тягнуться кілометр.
Я це зроблю і перенесу на полотно,
і, може, в майбутньому люди будуть бачити,
що був такий Василь,
якого назвали Сонячний чорнобривець.
А чого Сонячний чорнобривець?
Бачите, то — чорнобривці, а то — соняшник.
Коли я садив чорнобривці,
то називали Василь-чорнобривець,
а як почав ще й соняшники [садити],
то став Сонячний чорнобривець.
Ну зразу я так до того ставився [сором'язливо],
тепер думаю: «Коли народ дав таке звання в Україні,
то треба ж гордитися!» [сміється]
Я й сам дивуюся:
де береться така сила, натхнення
щоб такі території долати.
Розумієте?
Одній людині.
Коли ти стоїш, і метр зробити важко,
бо відчуваєш, що то важка фізична праця.
І коли воно все розцвітає, розумієте,
і ти їдеш, то забуваєш про все на світі,
повірте мені,
ти їдеш і усміхаєшся до тих квітів, і вони до тебе усміхаються.
Це треба полюбити!
Полюбити і відчути.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олег Сологуб]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Монтажерка
Люда Кучер]
[Музика
Sasha Boole]
[Субтитрувальниця
Оля Стулій]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]